c'est officiel l'arménie n'a plus de
chaque d'état major le décret du premier
ministre limogeant le chef des armes est
entrée en vigueur cette nuit nikol
pashinian en l'accusent d'être à
l'origine d'un coup d'état
la résolution avait été retoqué deux
fois or le président la crise politique
semble s'intensifier l'opposition devant
toujours le départ du premier ministre
les précisions de notre envoyé spécial à
yoann david khalifa pas d'évolutions
majeures depuis est deux jours ici à
erevan si ce n'est l'officialisation en
ce vendredi du limogeage du chef
d'état-major de l'armée onic agace
pariant un rassemblement est prévu à
demain devant le ministère de la défense
à 13h heure locale par c l ancien
militaire afin de contester cette
éviction qui semblait inévitable puisque
le président arménien ne pouvais pas
refuser à la demande du premier ministre
arménien nikol pashinian selon la
constitution arménienne à savoir qu'avec
une autre mobilisation d'ampleur est
attendu ici devant le parlement arménien
à l'appel de vazgen manoukian
principales figures de l'opposition
parlementaire
son nom a été proposé un par le
parlement pour remplacer le premier
ministre arménien en place à nikol
pashinian une mobilisation qui est
devrait se faire sous un important
dispositif de sécurité puisque la
sécurité a été renforcée autour des
bâtiments administratifs mais également
autour du parlement afin d'éviter qu'il
y ait toute tension entre manifestants
pro pashinian et anti pashinian à noter
également cette information qui vient de
l'inde et des proches de nicolas
pashinian concernant la tenue
d'élections législatives anticipées
elle semblerait inévitable selon à ses
propres mots pour rappel à l'opposition
ne souhaite pas ces élections
législatives anticipées si nikol
pashinian viendrait à se représenter une
nouvelle fois